Donald Trump has promised that if he is elected president
on his first day of office
he's going to pass an executive order which will prevent birthright citizenships
birthright citizenship is
a child born in the United States automatically becoming a United States citizen
such measures are to prevent undocumented parents
or parents that don't have any status to deliver a child in the United States
and then that child will become a United States citizen
his proposal would require at least one parent to be a United States citizen
or lawful permanent resident
in order for that child to be recognized as a United States citizen
politicians and experts have stated that this is not possible
as an executive order and would require a constitutional amendment
but it's interesting to see where the mindset is of the former president
and Republican candidate for 2024 presidency